the census is the catalyst of American
public policy it shapes voting districts
and it determines how your public
schools will get funded because this
data is used in myriad democratic and
economic functions it's critical that we
get it right
unfortunately the 2020 Edition might be
in trouble which has caused concern
among experts for the integrity of the
country's most authoritative data set
the census is centuries old but this
story starts at the conclusion of the
2010 census the Bureau had shot past
cost estimates on its way to the most
expensive census per capita of all time
so in 1970 it cost $16 to count each
housing unit and in 2010 it cost around
92 dollars to count each housing unit
this is all in 2020 dollars that's
robert goldenkoff his office redid the
2020 census on its list of government
initiatives at a high risk of failure a
key reason the funding just isn't there
Congress limited the budget for the 2020
census to the amount spent on the 2010
census the nation is getting more
complex and less willing to participate
in the census and because the
Constitution requires a complete count
the Census Bureau has to do more work in
order to obtain that complete count so
why might it cost more to count certain
groups this scene from an episode of
master of none gives some clues it
follows a cab driver back to his
apartment where he's living with at
least three other adult men so this one
apartment contains four distinct
households in New York City a region of
notoriously hard to count tracts
the census tracks are designated hard to
count for many reasons they could be
full of renters or they could have an
abundant homeless population
topographically complex regions are hard
to count as are tracks with limited
access to broadband internet it's the
people with the margins of society more
impoverished don't speak the language
then we have procedures to try to
compensate for that mr. Pruit would know
about the challenges in taking a census
he was director during the year 2000
count the last 2 to 3 percent of the
census is very expensive further
complicating matters a new proposal to
change the census could further increase
costs and effect response rates the
Department of Justice requested that the
bureau add a question about citizenship
to the short-form decennial census the
argument in the letter is that the
Justice Department wants better data on
where citizens are in the country in
order to enforce the voting rights laws
the citizenship question already appears
in the American Community Survey which
collects data annually
it just goes to a much smaller portion
of the country I can only do
consequences and I can say the
consequences of acting as if you need
this for the Voting Rights Act is
inconsistent with the fact that it
already exists a more complete dataset
on citizenship could give the Department
of Justice more granular data to work
with but that would depend on an
adequate response rate and the national
political climate might make that more
difficult some people have expressed
fear that the government might use
census data to aid deportations or
otherwise harm the communities we have
experienced in American history we're
being counted in the census didn't
result in painful consequences for the
Japanese who were interned Americans
today have a historically low level of
trust with their government that fact
paints an unsettling portrait certainly
today's environment if you told the
authorities where
a lot of undocumented people live the
authorities would I think take advantage
of that piece of information that's
their job I think the chances of having
a anything like a complete census if we
have the citizenship question is simply
off the case
they are proponents who favor a
mainstream citizenship question the
general argument is that census data are
used to apportion seats in Congress and
distribute funds but the Constitution
requires the census to count for all
persons that's because the census is a
survey of an economy that includes the
contributions of residents who aren't
citizens the stakes are rather we care
about about a representative democracy
the inequalities already economic
inequalities are severe if you duplicate
economic inequalities with political
inequalities then you simply have a
different kind of society and it's not a
democracy
[Music]
you
[Music]